wait a minute Neanderthals are extinct
before you laugh check yourself
Neanderthal DNA is 99.7% identical to
our own and researchers claim that some
humans might be carrying as much as 2%
of the Neanderthal genome making things
even weirder is that scientists recently
recovered a nearly complete DNA sequence
from a 50 thousand year old Neanderthal
skeleton so in theory Neanderthals could
make a comeback but how would they adapt
and how long would they survive this is
what if and here's what would happen if
Neanderthals hadn't gone extinct despite
their physical differences like being
shorter and having longer skulls we
might have more in common with
Neanderthals than we'd like to admit
first of all their brains were bigger
which doesn't make them smarter than us
but they could communicate with one
another they settled in family
communities and took care of the sick
and the elderly
they also crafted sophisticated tools
which would have been used for anything
from hunting to possibly shipbuilding
and they even cook their vegetables and
ate them which is more than you can say
so if Neanderthals are simply the beta
version of what humans became could they
still live among us Neanderthals in fact
did live among us for about 5,000 years
Homo sapiens and Neanderthals coexisted
in Europe and likely interbred this
would explain why most Eurasians
probably have at least 1% of the
Neanderthal DNA in their genome while
any one of African descent doesn't have
any Neanderthal DNA since their
ancestors didn't migrate through Eurasia
but with the homo sapien population
significantly outnumbering in the and
earth all population it's likely that
modern humans simply absorbed the
Neanderthal species another theory is
that we out competed them for resources
during the last ice age resulting in
their extinction but whichever theory is
right what if the concluding fact was
what if Neanderthals were not extinct
if Neanderthals somehow evolved as a
separate but very similar species to
humans how would they fare
despite their communication and
craftsmanship abilities the laws of
natural selection prove that Homo
sapiens are superior which means the
survival options for Neanderthals
wouldn't be that great barring the
likelihood of early modern humans
breeding them out of existence
Neanderthals probably would have become
something like second-class citizens
would we enslave them keep them in zoos
or force them to fight it's hard to say
with the limits of their intelligence
prevent them from fully integrating into
modern society or would they learn and
evolve just like Homo sapiens
maybe they'd want nothing to do with us
realizing how our differences outweigh
our similarities could we expect
Neanderthals to establish their own
communities and continue to exist
independently of the developing world
it's hard to predict exactly how a
species that went extinct about 40,000
years ago would behave today but then
again maybe we just have to look around
us Neanderthals may be extinct but we
did evolve alongside them and some of us
inherited more than others so think
twice before you call someone a
Neanderthal it can be quite offensive
and for more enlightening topics stay
tuned for more what if